ich eigentlich gesagt in bled viele
tiere geradezu aufgabe wartet junge ich
glaube im moment junge tot
nein christliche werte gestorben es war
ich erfreut wohl vergessen dass auch bei
tag fand das spannend wenn es regnet
ibla sie da bitte ich dich einfach und
schnell
ich habe mir eine abgabe nicht bekommen
als ob ich habe mit der hand ab das
falsch
hallo meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen verlor infolge des minecraft
tv projekt zusammen mit komme der mich
hier aus nach weil ich einmal eine
epische begrüßung machen möchte halt wir
werden also löw hier könntest du bitte
ruhig sein das ist mein teil
wir treffen uns nun auf dem server wird
leben natürlich in unterschiedlichen
städten
allerdings komme ich will auf ich will
auf gälisch machen und wie habe ich
meinen server genannt einfach nur babbel
server kunde steht der server wird
gestartet ja da steht bei mir auch schon
oft am anfang so allerdings bin ich auf
dem weg dahin hat darauf ich habe
irgendwie fällt kaum auf anders kapiert
rechts unter die karte gemacht findet
ihr das gute da wollte ihr die lieber
hierhin haben schreibt mal bei mir
lieber hier in liga dazu kommen direkt
über groß genau genau einfach zu kommen
einfach wird jemand früher in mein haus
gerichtet regnet bei dir auch bei mir ja
ich bin in der wüste bei mir raus gehen
heute bei mir in dem haus wo ich gerade
gehaust haben dem manager zu oracle hat
anscheinend adel und simon auch ihr haus
anbieterin das heißt der mehr ihre
kompletten thron gelagert achso übrigens
in die kamera gesagt hat in
verschiedenen städten ich bin in der
stadt der weide also an die zuschauer
von komme wenn ihr sehen wollt wie den
weiter aussieht könnt ihr das bei mir
sehen wo wir hier sind hier wunderschön
mit ganz vielen tür magazin gegnern und
wenn meine zuschauer sehen wie die wüste
aussehen könnte jetzt einfach mal
vorbeischauen
dann dehnt ihr bei der alle sagen ich
bin jetzt hier jetzt schon kiste und
alles aber ich glaube ja das ist hier
sogar tische und so das ja schon so und
ich möchte mal eben schnell schauen ob
noch mein buch bei dem todesort vom
league denn ich will der gestorben du
auch oder bist du weißt du wie das bei
uns festgehalten wurde
wie den roten fans hat das dahin
gestellt contractor start beim anal und
wuchtig wird verfolgt also weg jedoch
sohn habe code wurst so einfach genannt
und er ist einfach da steht einfach gut
wusste und nach cottbus zu beginnen und
bei mir steht einfach ein ass also
männlich also unser grabstelle ist echt
so nur noch fünf zähler da würde ich dir
mal anguckt es ist einfach richtig
wenn sich das auch richtig eingeschränkt
ehrlich jubel wenn du hier dabei gewesen
wärst hier war so eine katze sind so die
hat mich abgeholt mit engen sonar
schreiben kugel und dabei vergisst alles
alter das packe ja er wird ja schon vor
den braunen bären getötet ich werde es
auf jeden fall ganz ganz vorsichtig
vorgehen ich werde auch diese ganzen
sachen mitnehmen
diese teile hier weiter raus bekommt man
wo sind sie hin und da emerald charts
raus und ich möchte diese teile auch am
liebsten bei mir irgendwo hin pflanzen
also ich weiß nicht ob ich diese emerald
chart jetzt was macht man mit dem rad
halten könnt ihr wirklich bitte leute
schreibt mir ganz ganz viel in die
kommentare
ja auf alles was ihr wisst über heck
sind einfach alles genau bei meinem
ersten preis ich habe das auch ganz
deutlich eigentlich dieser spiele
komplett viele bekommen bekommen ich
muss gerade auch lassen als erwartet
ich habe jeden moment junge tot nein du
bist nicht märz gestorben es war ich hab
vergessen dass auch bei tag bond das
spannend wenn es regnet kraft ist
gestorben
ich habe etwas was du jetzt mag ich
schreibe jetzt jemanden aus meiner stadt
konnte ja noch mit einer meinen
grabstein dahin holen kann weist ich
würde das gerne machen mehr aber du bist
einfach mal fünfter noch viel weiter von
der bank zehntausender gewisse von mir
weg info der stadt complete leute nicht
betreut dem folge bitte holt meinem
grabstein
ich glaube du hast diesmal sogar feuer
zeit her die meint mond über bietet sage
ich mal
ich bin auch in der letzten folgen
wieder zwei männer gestorben
aber du bist hier doch dann minute
gestorben
das war aber echt so nenne ich habe so
eine spinne gehört und ich darf mir so
scheiße junge ist eine spinne dadurch
wird den aufpassen jetzt und ich glaubte
wieder in die stadt und skelett schießt
mich in der höhle rein und dann hat mich
ein pinguin oder kannst du kürzlich
gucken getötet hat als beweis für ein
skelett eines gelten schreibt alle
spiegeln in die kommentare weil die
weiblichen rollen lassen
ich hatte schon vorher blöde erlebnis
walter hat pinguine gefahren beim start
diese alle auf mich gegangen alle
pinguine titel dieser blödmann und jetzt
boxen mich die pinguine hier dass du
bist einfach mal vor und wie ist so in
meinem stab sich noch richtig gern rede
begeistert einfach anschreiben sagt
vielleicht kommt der solche kommentare
wie hart ist denn die kleinen gruppen
wie wohl ich bin sonst wo einen
grabstein holen dauert ja
woher bekomme ich nahrung deutlich
brauchen nahrung ich habe keine nahrung
wählt die evag scheiße alter es kann
doch nicht wahr sein es kann doch nicht
wahr sein dass ich bin hier ein paar
hundert ja auch nicht schlecht für todt
habe ich nicht hier irgendwie pflanzen
die man essen kann
nun denn wenn wir das 3 minuten keiner
geschrieben hat dann einfach mit ihnen
weiter und ich werde jetzt gerade
verbrennen zombie bei mir und bei kupfer
hier was ich kann sie jetzt darauf
warten musste
was zuckerrohr wüste ohne schnitt
beobachtet auch diene
ich habe mir extra links raussuchen
schwert arbeiten ebenso schwert an bord
ist ein boot ist das schon piratenschiff
und dann geht es einfach nicht weil
chronik schreibt zero league schreibt
ich schätze sorry ich muss jetzt
aufnehmen mit simon ist der erste ist
wird das spiel eine minute hans du davor
schneiden nächstes eigentlich machen wir
die tiere hier ansonsten die ich nicht
weiter aufnehmen das ist in amazonien
mütze macht das echo von dem blizzard
ist ja selber tot was los ich bin schon
vergiftet beginnt ist oder liz hat er da
den darf man nicht irgendwie ob die
rechnung am 2 das dauert 20 sekunden
sagte kurz muss kurz lukas grabstein
holen und schneidest dass bei der
nächsten folge davon kräfte kannst
wirklich wunderbar schreiben oder
nachrichten dabei auch aussprechen
wirklich richtig toll
danke dass du eine idee wo ich nahrung
in der freien wildnis serbe kommt oder
nicht fügte mal zu konferenzen zum thema
heizung nicht weit von unserer aufnahme
du ich bin gestorben von einem pinguin
und wirklich gar nichts
wer nicht ganz auf dem server kommen
meinen grabstein dahin dauert die zeit
kommt gehörten dir ja und kannst du
ruhig zeit lassen
72 weiß ich ich studiere seit fünf
minuten und quatsch einfach nur aber was
genau nützt es mir wenn ich jetzt den
grabstein holen oder sie weiter
aufnehmen darf ja aber du hast dann
morgen trotzdem absolut wäre ja ja das
ist klar aber ich glaube jetzt weiter
aufnehmen also blöd wenn ihr das video
grad seht es trat der 19
wenn ihr wenn ich mir nehmen gerade auch
am 19 und die folge kommt dann
wahrscheinlich am 21
dann am 20 nichts hoch bleiben darf
münchen aber ich kann nicht zu nah ran
wo kommst du ja ich bin extrem hexe
starten möchte euch nichts tun
dank schreibt mal eine kommentare daumen
hoch zu ross sonniges wetter möchte euch
nichts tun so okay ich habe ein wenig
chic währenddessen kann ich zeigen dass
mit bei media markt gekauft habe ich
erwartet hatte so oder da ist jemand
draufgezahlt mensch stellt die risiko-
oder leute die mir vorher nächsten volk
ich bin jetzt mal auch gestorben und ich
muss jetzt conny retten gehen weil conny
ist wie immer wieder verreckt verpackung
guck dir das an zimmern ii kuck die
doppelten meine aufnahme an dem sv
westerrade er ist in seiner höhle wenn
du aus der stadt zum friedhof läuft ich
dachte jetzt direkt nach jahr vom spawn
zum friedhof und am tag hinter seinem
wieder los - 5000 bürger niedrig ich
schwöre ich traue dich nicht okay okay
okay warnung
ich hab ja soll ich denn sagen ich kann
ja nicht wie es bauen also das ist
das dunkel ich ach so ich dir warnick du
wenn du von dect stadtkirche von der
stadtkirche in richtung friedhof gehst
und dann weiter geradeaus
ich weiß auch okay friedhof zum friedhof
und den geradeausverkehr mache und dann
das eine kleine höhle ja genau die ist
ein bisschen größer da oder links
daneben dann ich finde das nicht okay
nein nein links daneben glaube ich finde
ich für meine zeit ich bin eigentlich
nicht wieder heraus links daneben
sachsen
ja links daneben während der höhle oder
wie neben der höhe ist noch seine hülle
links liegen wie kann ich das
beschreiben darf ich mich auf fußball
kriegen
in den erst habe ich kann kämpfen dass
man sie auch innerlich so komme halt die
fresse einfach halten
ich habe den aufnahmen nach bei den
koordinaten der aufnahme macht getroffen
hat und dann schaust du nach wodurch
glauben bislang konnten sich laut frank
hartmann ich bin der ebene um fotos
bildschirm deswegen ich mache
wir haben einfach weil ich habe sogar
einmal über alles ich habe mich bekommen
ich habe mit der hand abwehrte falsch
ist es bald heißen hero projekt das
eigentlich nicht eigentlich geht das
der handel dürfe nicht gedruckt als ob
nicht warum du hast jetzt meine ganzen
sachen oder wie leise war nur ein
grabstein schon drauf konkret an
konkreter com crafter crafter viermal ja
dann setzt eben was anderes da hin und
dann setzen wir das aber das ist ja
wieder müsste gedroppt sein
ich kam im derby spawn bild schmitz bei
mir auch gar nicht mehr an der macht
halten wollen eher trocken
ich kann da nichts klicken irgendwie auf
einmal durch sind so hält sich einfach
hier ist denn ich muss nochmal ganz kurz
und machen so liebe leute ich darf nicht
mehr auf den server drauf meint simon
weil irgendwie grabstein oder so der
hätte die mit der pizza geboren müssen
dieser penner kann ich nicht jetzt darf
ich deswegen nicht weiterspielen und
konnte deswegen einen plan mit den
schwertern nicht umsetzt machen
allerdings ist das ist eine folge wohl
schon mal gesehen hat passt das mit der
fei scam wollte dass ich das tor mit dem
und anderen stadt teilnehmern aufnehmen
und wie gefällt euch das also ihr könnt
ihr auch kommentare schreiben und bombe
auch ganz viel über hero und heck sind
allgemein so was wir machen sollen so
weil wir uns halt nicht auskennen
deswegen will ich erstmal sagen jetzt
trotzdem gefallen hat trotz der fans
dann gibt einen daumen hoch ausgefallen
und schreibt ist das in den kommentaren
wir sehen dann von mir aus genau wie
sieht es dann von mir aus beim nächsten
mal wieder